hey guys Ryan right here so today is
April 1st April Fool's Day I don't have
a prank because I had some in mind all
the rejects are so [ __ ] busy these
days we're all being adults growing up
ejaculating for the first time we've all
hit puberty in her twenties but I wanted
to take the time to catch up on shout
outs tell you guys some truths about
some subscribers you know cuz I know
these subscribers personally I'm very
close to all of them so this is all
truth no lives on April Fool's Day
Paden gantt hey Ryan just want to say
keep up the good work you always make me
smile and if this turns into a shout-out
please make it awesome try to say my
name right I don't want to sound like an
[ __ ] but you do Payton's an [ __ ]
in real life just so you guys know but a
lot of people get my name wrong it's
Gant not grant yeah I'm not a [ __ ]
idiot Payton you don't think I can tell
there's no R in their last name yeah I'm
glad we could always make you smile
nothing like making an [ __ ] smile a
gaping smile Caden is actually a an
abuser of midgets he's a [ __ ] phobia
that's what he has it's a real thing
it's hatred towards midgets I told you I
want to let you guys in on the truth of
these people you guys are all earning
your shoutout that's right now Isaac fog
can I have a shout out please
you see Isaac the rules are you're
supposed to say something interesting
and then I give a shout out that way I
have something to work off of oh yeah
your little Asian boy good little Asian
boy as always I think I should give you
a piece of advice being Asian it's gonna
be a hard in the real world man even in
Asia
Asians are not white these are facts as
you go to school and as you get really
good in math like the rest of the Asians
you will want to get a girl one day and
when you want that girl it's just like
doing math you've got solved the problem
my friend Kofi I'm all cool
this guy is a he's a worldwide
organization terrible
I can earn a shout out by saying
something interesting so something
interesting you get it yeah yeah you're
not the first one to come up with that
joke Kofi let's see what you look like
Kofi some facts about Kofi he's really
into bondage he really likes it when the
girl wears a strap-on and puts it up his
butthole and then he goes oh no he's a
little kid he doesn't like doing any of
that didn't I realize that no photos of
you today buddy
there's many kinds of Kofi cameras out
there the music of P L plus s the police
hey guys give me a shout-out and get my
name right what is up with these demands
to get your names right you guys think
I'm a literary or something but your
reactions are the best the guests are on
point - yeah I know but it's really
about me [ __ ] - yes keep it up the
musical please yeah dude oh he does DBZ
that's right I know this guy he does
Christian heavy metal goth music he
often performs outside a hot topics and
then gets arrested by police not because
his music is violent just because it's
inappropriate to play outside a hot
topic without a permit I last shoutout
for April Fool's Jacob Flores hey Ryan I
am a new fan of your reactions I have a
question how do you meet so many hot
girls that have YouTube channels
primarily all of them excluding Veronica
are prostitutes that you can rent
because you can't buy a prostitute you
know imagine buying a prostitute you you
own a prostitute and there's always at
your houses like it's uncomfortable
so you rent prostitutes but I don't have
sex with any of them they're just here
to [ __ ] perform on the show how does
that [ __ ] up Alyssa's a prostitute
Sally's a prostitute these are all
truths Katie's a prostitute Brandy's a
[ __ ]
even Dan's a prostitute Jerry's that are
pimped I go through Jerry to get the
prostitutes is there like a youtube
martyr club I'm not aware of all right
no no I'm telling you it's uh it's just
like Netflix it's prosthetics that
sounds like a place you fix your
prostate PS I'm also a fan of your
brother's sick kungfu man no one should
bring up my brother too
my channel my channel nothing about
Anthony you guys get that he's not
talking to me right now
I had a housewarming party and I forgot
to invite him now he's been ignoring me
for the past month it's really
depressing I've been diving into a lot
more drugs lately ever since it's crazy
and I get most of my drugs from Jacob
Florida's actually so yeah we've learned
a lot about some of our subscribers
Jacob is a drug dealer Kofi is a clean
young african-american boy
Isaac corn is gonna be a mathematical
Asian with genius woman and Peyton Gant
is an [ __ ] these are all truths I'm
kidding April Fool's Day people none of
that's true you want a shout-out you can
go to facebook.com slash the real reject
shadows where I will try to be nicer
next time get it the prank was I'm
telling truths about people that are not
true and everyone bought it no I was
very specific as to knowing these people
and saying details about their lives my
only friends would know yeah and the
subscribers believed all of it but I was
lying it was a prank that's how much
hard work I put into this channel